Shami maybe a new kid on the block but
the scrappy Chinese cellphone maker
known as little rice is no longer little
CEO lei Jun helped found the company in
April 2010 just four months later Xiaomi
officially launched its first Android
based firmware called new UI in 2011
Xiaomi took on apple with its first
smartphone the me one and just like
Apple Xiaomi has introduced new products
every year with great fanfare so how did
Xiaomi rise so far so fast
first there's the price at $270 the
flagship me3 costs less than half of the
cheapest iPhone in China then there's
the business strategy Xiaomi cells
directly to consumers online with
limited quantity available a recent
one-day web sale in China brought in 241
million dollars in orders when its
flagship product the me3 launched last
year xiaomi sold 100,000 phones in under
90 seconds xiaomi he plans to expand
outside of china to 10 new markets and
triple shipments from 19 million to 60
million phones by the end of this year
and xiaomi just dropped the little from
its domain name proving this 10 billion
dollar startup is starting to think a
lot bigger